StStéphanie Grammond, Alec
CaCastonguay, Luc Ferrandez.
BoBonsoir à vous trois.
- - (tous): Bonsoir.
- - Visite éclair de M. Trudeau
ququi est allé rencontrer le
prprésident Zelensky. Je vais vs
fafaire entendre et M. Trudeau t
MoMonsieur Zelensky.
- - Les Canadiens vont toujours
êêtre solidaires de l'Ukraine.
PaPas seulement parce qu'on est
amamis avec l'Ukraine mais bien
ssûr en l'est, mais aussi parce
quque les principes qu'on est en
trtrain de défendre, que les
UkUkrainiens sont en train de
dédéfendre avec leur vie contre
l'l'invasion illégale de Vladimr
PoPoutine, sont des principes qi
nonous gardent tous en sécuritéà
trtravers le monde et qui doivet
êêtre défendus à chaque étape.
LeLe Canada est un leader, dit e
prprésident Zelensky. Et il este
dedeuxième après les États-Unis.
DiDifficile d'en demander plus.
C'C'est vraiment une déclaration
ququi a dû faire plaisir à la
vivice-première ministre et au
prpremier ministre Trudeau.
- - Oui, et en même tempsps, ça
pepermet de décocher une petite
flflèche aux Européens. Parce qe
lele numéro un et deux de sont s
dedes pays en Europe, alors que
leles frontières de l'Europe sot
memenacées par la Russie. Ça
pepermet à Zelensky d'envoyer ue
pepetite claque en arrière de la
ttête à la France et à
l'l'Allemagne et à d'autres pay.
MaMais oui, c'est d'avoir une
vivisite qui est d'abord
imimportant.
LeLes symboles en diplomatie sot
trtrès importants. Deuxième pays
dudu G7 en tant que dirigeant se
dédéplacer après origine jeune.
OnOn est un allié depuis longtes
dedepuis l'Ukraine. Depuis 1991,
onon reconnaît l'indépendance de
l'l'Ukraine. On ne formait des
sosoldat ukrainien au sein de
l'l'OTAN.
JeJe pense que Zelensky a raison
enen disant qu'on voudrait peut-
êêtre faire plus, mais qu'on ne
popourrait pas. On n'a pas autat
dede stocks en réserve comme les
EÉtats-Unis, qui peuvent faire
plplein de dons.
MaMais la vie diplomatique Justn
TrTrudeau est allée apporter, je
pepense que ça, les Ukrainiens
popour le prendre de bonnes
fafaçons.
- - Oui, visite Clara, mais c'et
ququand même une visite. C'est e
sese rendre là, sur place.
CÇa a un poids énorme.
- - Et en plus, il faut dire que
cece n'est pas juste le fait de
s's'y rendre, c'est le fait quee
CaCanada peut jouer un rôle
d'd'influence auprès des pays qi
sosont contre l'Ukraine et poura
RuRussie. Quand on regarde nos
mémédias, on a l'impression quee
momonde entier et pour l'Ukrain.
NoNon. L'Inde, le Brésil, et
susurtout le Brésil, je vais
l'l'expliquer pourquoi, continue
d'd'encourager la Russie.
IlIl a déclaré que Monsieur
ZeZelensky est autant coupable e
VlVladimir Poutine des morts.
TrTrudeau peut jouer un rôle. Il
pepeut être un partenaire de
l'l'Amérique du Sud et tenter de
jojouer de son influence. Cette
vivisite a demande son engageme,
mamais il pourrait y avoir des
susuites.
- - Stéphanie, vous êtes d'accod
susur l'importance de la visite
- - Je pense que oui. Le Canadan
a a déjà fait beaucoup avec le
trtrio de ministre, Mme Joly,
MaMadame Anand, et... on sait
ququ'elles ont beaucoup démené
dedepuis le début de la gare. Ms
jeje pense que c'était important
quque Justin Trudeau se présent.
CÇa a une valeur de symbole. Le
fafait d'être à Kiev, qui est ue
viville, évidemment, on aurait u
pepenser lors des premières heus
dede l'évasion, que la Russie en
feferait une seule bouchée.
FiFinalement on se rencontre que
dedeux mois plusus tard, ce n'et
papas le cas. Si le premier
miministre du Canada peut se
rerendre l là-bas en sécurité, t
quque manifestement, ça tient b.
C'C'est un symbole important à
enenvoyer.
OnOn considère que c'est possibe
dede rouvrir l'ambassade.
C'C'est une fleur que Monsieur
ZeZelensky lui envoie en disant:
vovoilà, vous êtes parmi les
prpremiers en haut de la liste
paparmi les pays qu'on peut
reremercier.
C'C'est bien pour M. Trudeau qui
sese fait parfois reprocher de e
papas en faire assez. Mais je
pepense qu'elle a hauteur de nos
momoyens, on a contribué, en
imimposant des sanctions et en
ététant en avant-garde de ce cô-
llà.
- - On a ici le drapeau devant
l'l'immeuble de l'ambassade
cacanadienne à Kiev. On a rouvet
l'l'ambassade.
PoPour la diplomatie, non pas pr
leles choses consulaires. Mais n
sese dit que ça viendra.
- - C'est peut-être la seule
pepetite tâche dans ce dossier u
ccôté du Canada, c'est qu'on a
enencore beaucoup de difficultés
avavec les services consulaires
popour les réfugiés, comme au tt
dédébut, et comme on a eu en
AfAfghanistan. C'est un service
ququi est devenu très
dydysfonctionnel lorsqu'une crie
écéclate à quelque part.
OnOn se demande quelle est sa
popolitique officielle en gestin
dede crise. Dès que ça brasse un
pepeu, confirme notre ambassade.
ToTous les pays ne font pas ça.
L'L'Frans n'a jamais fermé son
ambassade à Kiev.
EnEn Afghanistan, les Britanniqs
sosont restés très longtemps, le
plplus longtemps possible.
- - Les Français aussi.
- - Nous, on quitte avant qu'ile
papasse quoi que ce soit.
- - Les les Ukrainiens nous ont
aiaidé.
- - Ils ont sorti nos interprèts
dede là-bas. Peut-être que la
prprochaine étape, c'est de
reremettre ça en place. Quels st
leles critères qui guident le
miministre des Affaires
ététrangères. Est-ce qu'on
popourrait rester un peu plus
lolongtemps pour donner un coupe
mamain? Là c'est peut-être
l'l'endroit où on encore des
ttâches. Mais sinon la visite
plplutôt était bien été.
- - 11 départs annoncés.
DeDes piliers dans certains cas,
ququi était arrivé soit sous M.
ChCharest, ou ensuite, bref.
JeJe vous fais entendre M. Arca,
MaMadame Anglade, et la candidae
DaDanville Mont-Royal-Outremont.
PIPIERRE ARCAND, député, PLQ
MoMont-Royal-Outremont
- - Je confirme le fait que
jeje ne vais pas solliciter
unun nouveau mandat dans la
cicirconscription de Mont-Royal-
OuOutremont aux élections
dudu mois d'octobre prochain.
A Après plus d'une quinzaine
d'd'années en politique, le tems
esest venu de laisser ma place
àà une nouvelle génération,
ququi va apporter des nouvelles
ididées également pour le Québe.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chefeffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - C'est clair que pour le Pari
lilibéral du Québec, il y a une
pépériode de renouveau parce qul
y y a des gens qui ont contribué
àà la vie politique de manière
trtrès... très forte.
EtEt je pense que Pierre en est
unun bon exemple, une énorme
cocontribution. Je pense qu'il
n'n'y a presque pas de postes qe
PiPierre Arcand n'a pas occupés
auau sein de notre formation
popolitique. Mais encore une fo,
jeje pense que, comme formation,
onon est plus riche de toute cee
exexpérience-là. On est capable
dede pouvoir compter sur
leles conseils, l'expérience,
leles idées qu'ils amènent.
MaMais en même temps, ça attire
dedes personnes qui ont envie de
fafaire de la politique pendant
leles 10, les 15 prochaines
anannées avec nous.
MIMICHELLE SETLAKWE, candidate,
PLPLQ, Mont-Royal-Outremont
- - La pandémie nous a amenés
àà réfléchir et à identifier
cece qui compte le plus dans
nonos vies. Nous devons urgemmet
poposer les gestes qui s'imposet
popour créer de la richesse
papartout au Québec, tout en
prprotégeant l'environnement.
AÀ mon sens, les sujets à saveur
nanationaliste, identitaire,
ququi nous divisent, ne devrait
papas occuper autant de place
dadans le débat public.
MaMadame Setlakwe a en tête la i
2121. M. Legault, étonnamment, i
s's'est déjà mêlé de la partie n
didisant que le PLQ présent une
cacandidate anti nationaliste àa
viville Mont-Royal.
C'C'était assez étonnant. Jour ,
lele jour n'est même pas termin,
etet le premier ministre qui set
mmêle.
EtEt d'autres questions : quand
mmême, on veut qu'il y ait un
roroulement de génération, maisa
cocommence à faire beaucoup de
dédépart. Mais d'abord, sur
l'l'arrivée de Mme Setlakwe. Tor
dede table.
- - D'abord, Monsieur Legault na
papas beaucoup d'ambition dans
MoMont-Royal-Outremont.
IlIl veut se présenter comme le
chchampion du Québec, le champin
nanationaliste, ça lui permettrt
popour lui de répéter qu'elle à
seses yeux les libéraux ne sont
papas nationalistes et que cette
cacandidature le prouve. Mais ça
n'n'a rien à voir avec sa lutte
lolocale. C'est un message qui
vivisait l'ensemble de la
popopulation et la campagne
élélectorale. Sur la campagne ds
lilibéraux, c'est un mélange. Iy
enen a beaucoup qui ont donné
bebeaucoup à la politique, qui
sosont là depuis longtemps, M.
ArArcand en fait certainement
papartie.
IlIl y en a d'autres pour qui
prprobablement les sondages
dédéfavorables, l'idée de passer
ququatre années possiblement das
l'l'opposition ne leur sourit ps
bebeaucoup. Ça sollicite peut-êe
unun peu leur décision. Il y a
pepeut-être mélange des deux.
OnOn va probablement se rende à0
% % du caucus. C'est quand même
bebeaucoup.
- - C'est beaucoup!
- - Si on reprend l'analogie du
hohockey, ça prend des années pr
enencadrer les jeunes si on ne
veveut pas une série de défaite.
IlIl faudra trouver un mélange u
PaParti libéral, parce que c'est
bibien de faire maisonnette, mas
çaça prend de l'expérience socie
àà l'assemblée nationale.
- - En entreprise, on trouverait
çaça assez élelevé. Ce sont dess
cacanons, de grandes pointures i
s's'en vont. Monsieur Arcand et
MaMadame Thériault, ce sont des
gegens qui ont fait beaucoup.
MaMadame Thériault, quand il étt
auau ministère de la consommati,
ququi a changé beaucoup de chos.
IlIl y en a d'autres qui n'ont s
anannoncé encore, mais on est ds
l'l'incertitude. M. Leitao, quia
étété ministre des finances. C't
àà lui qu'on doit le grand ménae
dedes finances publiques. Le
prpremier ministre actuel est le
prpremier à le reconnaître. Ce
sosont des gens qui sont quand
mmême d'expérience. S'il qu'il
totous en même temps, oui le
rerenouveau, mais c'est sûr quea
vava être un défi.
OnOn va voir. Mme Setlakwe, c'et
inintéressant, on dirait qu'elle
sese positionne plus ferme sur s
enenjeux nationalistes.
LeLe Parti libéral avait essayée
séséduire un peu plus l'électort
frfrancophone précis d'aller
chchercher plus de votes à
l'l'extérieur de Lille. Mais on
sasait que les parties anglophos
ququi vont peut-être se former,u
ququi sont en train de l'être. n
lala voit se positionner de façn
plplus ferme, c'est peut-être un
memessage qu'elle essaie d'envor
dede ce côté.
- - Luc : deux questions.
MoMonsieur Legault, qui va faire
flflèche de tout bois, pour
momontrer qu'il est le champion
nanationaliste ici et que toutes
crcritiques de la loi 21 devient
unune critique anti nationalist.
- - Oui, c'est le rôle qu'il jo.
EtEt en même temps, pour la loi
9696, ça va chauffer des autres
ccôtés aussi, en disant : vous
n'n'allez pas assez loin, vous e
prprenez pas assez de précautio,
vovous êtes trop timide. En se
prprésentant et disant : je suis
lele représentant du juste-mili,
momoi aussi je défends le
nanationalisme québécois par
rarapport au Parti libéral.
MaMaintenant, par rapport à la
ququestion des départs, c'est ue
chchose dans le parti d'oppositn
etet que tu perds des pour centt
quque tu as une chance réelle de
gagagner après quatre ans, mais
c'c'est une autre chose arrivée
dadans un parti et qu'il n'y a
auaucune chance peut-être
d'd'arriver au pouvoir dans quae
anans. Donc c'est huit ans dans
l'l'opposition. L'opposition,
c'c'est quelque chose qui use. l
fafaut être au courant de tous s
dodossiers, constamment en mode
vivigilance est critique. C'est
loloin d'être facile.
- - Voilà.
- - C'est loin d'être facile de
rerecruter des gens.
- - Vous êtes déjà rendu loin,
huhuit ans.
- - Malheureusement, les chiffrs
nonous disent que à moins d'un
rerenversement rapide...
- - Oui, à la prochaine, à moins
d'd'un renversement rapide, mais
l'l'autre dans quatre ans, c'est
trtrès loin.
- - Il faudrait que le Parti
lilibéral réussisse son virage
nanational. Et d'ailleurs,
papatience pour le Parti libéra.
AuAu moment où ils annonçaient
ququ'il y allait avoir une
chcharte... Guy Lafleur meurt le
mmême jour. Alors aucune chance
dadans la réinvention. C'est paé
sosous silence. On ne sait pasùu
çaça va aller.
- - André Arthur, phénomène quia
frfrappé à peu près sur tout le
momonde.
OnOn va écouter M. Arthur lui-
mmême, quelques réactions, et on
rerevient après.
ALALAIN DUFRESNE, directeur,
CoCollège Radio Télévision de Qc
- - Arthur disait : "Je revendie
lele droit de m'adresser
àà mes auditeurs comme je parle
àà mes amis. Alors, ça a changé
lele ton avec lequel les
ananimateurs s'adressaient au
pupublic en ondes. Je pense que.
jujusqu'au milieu des années 80,
totout le monde travaillait d'ue
fafaçon beaucoup plus coincée
enen ondes. Et par la suite, çaa
cocomme ouvert la porte à la fan
dede s'exprimer des animateurs.
- - Je l'écoutais, je travaiails
pupuis c'était jusqu'à temps
ququ'il ait fini son émission.
JeJe l'aimais beaucoup.
- - C'est triste, là. C'était
ququelqu'un qui était... Bien m,
j'j'aimais bien son franc-parle.
C'C'est pas quelqu'un qui avait
lala langue dans sa poche,
cocomme on dit.
IlIl a effectivement donné un
tetemps nouveau à la radio. Il a
cocontribué à une révolution dea
raradio. Ça reviendra beaucoup
apaprès quelques années.
ToTour de table. Luc Ferrandez,n
a a vu passer des réactions deps
hihier. Jusqu'à la toute fin, il
auaura été lui-même, en tout ca.
- - Oui, malheureusement.
EÉvidemment, c'est normal... Ily
a a une chanson de Ginette Reno
ququi disait que l'importance de
lala trémie, et sa famille
l'l'aimait.
LeLe don de la parole, le don de
lala communication, au service e
lala hargne, au service du chao,
dudu rejet d'une partie de la
popopulation, que ce soient les
hohomosexuels, musulmans...
jeje ne peux pas me réjouis de a
mamaman, mais je suis content
ququ'il soit enfin silencieux.
- - Je pense qu'il faut
rereconnaître l'excellent
cocommunicateur qu'il était. Je
susuis un peu d'accord sur le
susujet, comme Luc, parce qu'il
atattaquait les vulnérables.
JeJe les compare à la Chambre ds
cocommunes en 2006. Il a été
dédéputé indépendant.
LeLes conservateurs l'ont même
coconsidéré comme l'un des leurs
enen 2008. C'est finalement
l'l'vague orange de 2009 2011 qi
a a eu raison de M. Arthur. Il
n'n'était pas du tout à la chame
dedes communes comme il était àa
raradio. On s'attendait qu'il st
cocoloré, qu'il attaque tout
azazimut. Pas du tout. Il ne
paparlait pas aux médias, il
fafaisait son travail.
IlIl continuait à conduire son
auautobus.
MaMais les fois où il était à la
chchambre des communes, on ne pt
papas dire qu'il était équivalet
àà son personnage radiophonique.
CÇa nous a étonné à l'époque où
jeje le couvrais.
- - Stéphanie?
- - On ne peut pas nier qu'il
avavait le sens de la nouvelle,
paparce que lui-même a fait un
gagazouillis sur Twitter pour le
susujet de sa maman, alors il
avavait le scoop.
EÉvidemment, nos condoléances
vovont à sa famille, mais d'un
auautre côté, je ne peux pas
m'm'empêcher que son héritage en
tetermes journalistiques aura éé
plplutôt du côté de tous ces
sosouvenirs de ces procès en
didiffamation, de tout ce qu'ila
pupu dire.
- - Qu'il a perdu.
- - Diviser la population, ses
prpropos sur les noirs, les
mumusulmans. Tout ça est quand
mmême assez malheureux.
- - Merci beaucoup ou à vous